the Joe Rogan experience I don't even
try I'm a lightweight when I spoke with
Arnold was all the Dave Draper all these
muscle heads would come around you know
they got a big bomb and the thing was it
put like a like a an ounce in the bowl
and then they'd fired up and then the
shotgun is so hard whoever exploded the
the ball into the into the water made it
explode then you were the hero it's a
although all the muscle ads there
they're taking their hip arnold takes a
bigot you know the thing he explodes
then they hand it to be able they wasn't
chung and now with the chong at the time
so they just looked at me like yeah okay
go silver there's AG then you were just
a guy yeah I was just almost faceless
what was it like being famous for being
a pothead back in the 70s
cuz that had to be weird as you were you
were you and Cheech were famous pot
heads yeah
we're I don't think there was anybody
else like who else was a famous pot head
no no no one maybe no one ever named the
actor he did time he did a year in jail
in County for one joint Robert Mitchum
oh yeah Albert Mitchum but he was like a
straight-laced guy yeah the image bit of
cowboy yeah he's a tough guy
that was the image well you know what
the big the big draw for pot was the sex
see it it was it was before when you
call the Soper's or snow white Lutz
you know the quail in the quaalude was
big sex things that was people would
have sex on quaaludes oh yeah why yeah
I've never taken a quail it was it do
for you oh just it they're called
spreaders when a girl gets
the quaalude if they take me yeah do you
think that's why Bill Cosby was girls of
Crayola totally totally so that was the
thing that just relaxes you and to some
it makes you horny really oh yeah
and that's what pot does forever for me
now but no but it does for people for
women
yeah and love to sleep with that and
they love to have sex you know after
smoking joy where was Annie Hall was in
Annie Hall with woody was I and he got a
little pissed off do you have to get
high every time you make love with me
yeah that's I think was an taeho and I
think I think everybody in the picture
in the movie company in the movie house
says yeah I can dig it
yeah it definitely changes the way
things feel yeah it realizes yeah axis
you hear music Ben
[Applause]